You've been reading.
I I've been I read all of God's
messages. All of God's messages.
Nice. The Bible is amazing. The Torah is
amazing. The Quran is amazing.
It's all from the same author. I would
disagree that it's from the same author,
but you're on the right track. Would you
care to
I don't I believe that the Torah and the
Gospel come from God. I don't believe
the Quran comes from God. Why not?
Because it contradicts the Torah and the
Gospel. In what way? So, the Torah and
the Gospel teaches us that God is our
heavenly father. While the Quran is
emphatic about uh going against that
idea.
I'm sorry. You said that um the Torah
teaches you that Jesus is your heavenly
father? Yeah. That That That God the
Father That God the Father the person of
the Father is, you know, who has the
same divine essence as the Son.
He's our heavenly father.
And the Quran disagrees with that.
Wait, but did you know that the Jews,
they don't even believe Jesus is a
prophet?
It depends on what Jews you're talking
about. No, no. Most Jews don't believe
Jesus is a prophet. They think
astaghfirullah, you know? Well, yeah.
So, I I appeal to the scripture, not not
to Jews like, you know. Yeah, but I
mean, Avery, you said that Jews also
believe in Jesus. I'm telling you, Jews
do not believe in Jesus.
Yeah, you do. You have You have
Messianic Jews that believe in Jesus or
you And you also have a movement called
Jews for Jesus movement. Let's say Let's
say we got some Jews on the right track,
right? Yes. Because even as a Muslim,
you know, no Muslim has ever Muslim if
they don't believe Jesus is a prophet.
Okay. Where we differ is you believe
Jesus himself is God, right? That's
right. Okay. So, yeah, that's where we
differ.
So, we differ Yeah, that's where we
differ. What do you say to
about like John 16:13
when it says, "But when he comes, he
will guide you into all truth. He will
not speak on his own. He will speak what
he hears, and he will tell you of what
is to come."
Yeah, yeah. I'd say that that's talking
about the Holy Spirit who if you look at
verse seven, Jesus says that he sends
him.
He said verse seven? Mhm.
That's what he said for your own for
your good that I'm going away. Unless I
go away, the Advocate will not come to
you. But if I go, I will send him to
you. So, I would argue that, you know,
Muhammad is being prophesied here.
Because after Muhammad After Sorry,
after Jesus, peace be upon him, Muhammad
came. Yeah, I I know that this is what
you believe, but there there's problems
with that. So, for example,
you believe that Allah sent Muhammad,
right? Right.
Well, according to the verse, Jesus
sends the Spirit of truth. He sends the
Comforter.
So, if you're going to say that Muhammad
is the Comforter, then you would have to
say that Jesus is the one who sent
Muhammad, which would then make Jesus
Allah. That doesn't make no sense.
Which is why you should not say it's
about Muhammad. How can you say that
Jesus is the one sending him? Re- Re-
verse seven again. Re- verse Verse
seven, Jesus says, "I will send him All
right. And there's a little little bit
of a distortion of the audio, guys. Just
Just bear with us, please.
Okay. Okay.
All right. You see it? I have to look
into that more, but
let's agree to disagree for now. No,
Mimi. No. Avery Avery, you always pick a
claim and then you stick to it.
do you want?
Okay. So, what do you want me to say
then? I want you to be honest with what
the text plainly says. If since Jesus
says he's going to send him, you can't
say that that's about Muhammad because
you don't believe Muhammad was sent by
Jesus.
Sure. Okay. In this verse In this verse,
it says, "I will send him to you." Okay.
The context here is where he says, "I
will send him to you." Right. I don't
believe it's Jesus saying that. I
believe it's Allah saying that. But that
Hold on.
So, okay. But look. If you read the
verse, he says, "Truly, truly I say to
you,
it's good for you that I go away." You
think that's Allah speaking or is that
Jesus speaking? But did Jesus didn't
even write the Bible. No. No. No No
worries. This is This is still what he
said. It's recording his words.
He says,
"Truly, truly I say to you,
it's good for you that I go away."
Right? That's Jesus speaking, right? Or
is that Allah saying that? Okay, but do
you think God could ever really go away?
He's leaving the earth. He's His
presence is going up up back to heaven.
Okay. So,
You don't You don't You don't believe
that Allah
Advocate. So, who is the Advocate that's
going to come? The Holy Spirit. The Holy
Spirit. And Jesus sent him.
Jesus says this
in chap- in the previous chapters. If
you go to For example, go to chapter 14,
and then go to verse 26. So, go to
chapter 14, and then go to verse 26.
Jesus explicitly tells us who the
Advocate is. But the Advocate, the Holy
Spirit, whom the Father will send in my
name, will teach you all things and will
remind you of everything I've said to
you.
Okay.
See The Advocate is clear. I would say
that, you know, Muhammad is the one who
came down and reminded us of everything
that Jesus had said.
But see, the thing is There's one God.
Worship him only. Okay. But that would
be wrong though. Cuz one, he didn't do
that, and we can get into that in a
second. But let's just deal with the
immediate context here. So, you believe
that Muhammad is the Holy Spirit?
Who Jesus No, I believe that I believe
all prophets have the Holy Spirit in
them, right? That's why they're
prophets.
Okay. Nice. So, but the Holy Spirit
himself, you don't believe that that's
Muhammad, right? I don't believe that a
Holy Spirit is in self.
Well, that's what Jesus says.
Jesus says the Holy Spirit is a himself.
Yeah, but Avery, with all due respect,
me and you have a different idea of who
Jesus is, right? Yeah, but you came to
my scripture to talk about this. So, I'm
just breaking it to you down what the
scripture says. That's all. Okay, and
that's fine. We could agree to disagree
on this part. Well, we can't though. No.
No. No, it's not. This is why I'm saying
this. Like I I can't go go to your Quran
and say, "According to the Quran, you
know, Muhammad's not the prophet. He's
not the last prophet."
I wish you would go to the Quran. I do
all the time. But I don't believe that
the Listen to my example. Just listen to
my example. I'm just bringing it using
this as an example. I can't go to the
Quran, right, and have a discussion with
you and say, "You know, you know,
according to the Quran, Muhammad's not
the prophet." And you show me where it
literally says Muhammad is the seal of
the prophets. But I'm like, "You know
what? No, you know, let's just agree to
disagree here." No.
It It says what it says. I can't If I'm
going to be honest, I have to admit what
it says. Like now, if I'm going to be
honest, I can say, "Okay, yeah. The
Quran is clear that Muhammad is the last
prophet. However, I just don't agree
with what the Quran says here." Okay.
That I can do That's an honest position
to have.
Okay.
I'm saying for you, acknowledge that,
"Okay, yes. The Advocate, it's the Holy
Spirit. It's not Muhammad. So, but
however, I I don't agree with with what
the Bible is saying here." Okay, sure. I
don't agree with the with what the Bible
is saying here. Okay. Okay. I can take
that.
So, now what about John 5:30?
It says, "By myself I can do noth-
nothing. I judge as I hear, and my judg-
my judgment is just, for I seek not to
please myself, but him who sent me."
Yeah, what's your question about that?
So, him who sent me. Did Jesus send
himself? It's the Father. We believe in
the Trinity. So, Jesus is not the
Father. They're two distinct persons
that have the same nature. And Jesus
takes the form of a servant and uh
humbly serves the Father. Wait, but
if they're two distinct people, They're
not people.
then how can you say that Jesus is God
as well? Because them being distinct
persons doesn't mean that they have
separate eth- that they're separate in
their essence. Yeah, they don't have the
same mentality. Thanks. Sorry, Avery,
but they're saying two distinct people
is the same as saying two distinct
separate essence, isn't it? No. No, I'm
not. I'm not saying two different
people, by the way. I'm saying two
different persons that have have the
same essence. So, it's like this.
There's a difference between personhood,
what a person is, and the essence of a
thing. Your essence or your being is
what you are,
right? Personhood is the who you are.
So, like for example, and there are
things that have have being, right? That
have an essence that don't have
personhood.
For example, like a rock. A rock is a
being, right? It has an essence, right?
It has a state of existence.
You wouldn't say that a rock is a
person, right? Okay.
So, there's a difference between being
or essence, which are synonymous,
and personhood.
Now, when we go up the ladder, let's go
up the ladder. Let's get to humanity.
Every human being
is a singular human person, right?
Right? You agree? Okay.
I'm listening to you. So, with human
being human beings human beings do have
personhood. With every human being,
there is one human person. Now, let's go
up the the scale again.
Let's go to God. God is the divine
being. He has the divine essence. This
God Within this essence, there are three
persons. Well,
being So, when we're talking about the
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit, they have
the same being. They share the same
essence,
although they are three distinct persons
within
the Godhead within the Bible. But Avery,
like if you were to explain this to a
person who wasn't a Christian, like how
could you get them to follow that?
Because if you tell them It happens all
the time. Jesus, God, and the Holy
Spirit, it'll always be three. It'll
never be one. You're going to try and
take somebody's mind and morph all three
of these beings into being one thing on
its own? Well, I'm not I'm pretty clear
on what I'm saying, Mimi. But doesn't it
make more sense to say that there's one
God, and he sent many messengers down at
different times to different people to
show to give the message once again when
once they forgot that there's one God
and only he should be worshipped. Or
does it make more sense to say God is
three, but really he's one?
And in this essence he's like this and
in this essence he's like that. And
Muhammad doesn't exist. The Jews talk
about Jesus sometimes, but a lot of them
don't believe in him. Like what makes
more sense? Um so what you did was is
you mischaracterized what I said and
what I believe and I wouldn't do that to
you.
So with you with you saying does it make
more sense to say that there's one God
sent the prophets? I say the same thing.
Now where we get into the nitty-gritty
is whether or not those one God is
multi-personal or not. You believe he's
one person, I believe he's three persons
as the scripture says.
a person.
I believe You're
you're only
you're only saying you're only saying
that because you're not understanding
what personhood is. But you do believe
that God is a person as we just
described as person. Not at all. Not at
all. Mimi, let me break it down. Like
you you're cutting me off and I was
about to say Sorry to interrupt you, but
that's not what I believe about oh, you
know. Well, you don't you don't know you
don't know what I'm saying. That's why.
You know, so like what I'm saying is
like going over your head cuz you don't
know what I'm saying. So let me explain
it to you and then you can see that I'm
actually not going against what you
actually believe.
All right, go ahead. So personhood, when
I say a person, I'm talking about a
agent that has
that has intellect, emotions, a will,
and is self-aware.
That's the philosophical term of
personhood. Okay.
Okay? So you do believe that Allah has
intellect, has emotions, has a will, is
self-aware. You do believe these things.
So by definition you believe that Allah
is a person. He has personhood.
Okay? Not saying that he's human or you
know, a creation. That's not what that
means. It just simply means he has
intellect, emotion, will, and you know,
the self-awareness. Okay? That's what
I'm saying by personhood.
So you you believe that within the
nature of Allah
he only has one person.
What I believe about the nature of God
is that he has three persons, the
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit. And they
could be the that share the divine
essence.
That's what that's the difference of us.
We both believe in one God.
You just believe in one God is one
person. I believe the one God is three
persons. Well,
person to me is somebody like us who
goes to the washroom, who, you know,
cries some heartbreak, who who does
these things, who eats,
who goes out. That's a person living in
their personhood to me. That's That's a
human person. That's a human to you.
Yeah, but a person is still something on
Earth, right? Not necessarily. As I just
as I just described to you what I'm
saying by person.
By person I'm not saying human being. By
person I'm just saying an agent with
intellect, self-awareness, and a will.
That's all. So do you do you see how
that doesn't necessitate a creation?
That even that applies to God himself.
Well, but when you say agent, an agent
is somebody working for someone, no? No,
that's not what I mean by agency either.
Agency just awareness. Like, you know, a
being that has awareness and, you know,
intellect. That's what I mean by agency.
And, you know, with all due respect,
Avery, you're giving person your own
definition No, I'm not.
That's the philosophical term. No, a
person is a human being regarded as an
individual.
Actually, you what you're referring to
is the colloquial definition what modern
people use.
What Avery is using is the ancient
definition. It comes from the Greek word
hypostasis. So I mean, he's actually
using the old definition because that's
how we define
who we are.
Why why should I if I wanted to be a
Muslim, why should I think that Allah is
only one person? Because there's only
one God.
Sure, but just because you have one God
doesn't mean you have to have one
person. I don't believe God is a person.
Like I just don't understand like I just
I don't I don't think you need to have
one personal thing.
I don't believe I need to have only one
eye. I don't believe you need only need
to have one person that's able to
create. Why couldn't three
It's like you guys confuse it more for
yourselves. Like why not just think or
believe that there's one God, he loves
everybody. I believe there's one God and
I don't think your God loves everyone.
He doesn't. He loves those who love
everyone. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, he doesn't he
doesn't he doesn't like me. I'll be
honest. Allah loves those who love him,
who don't associate partners with him. I
don't associate any partners with God.
Like if I if I say God is one and I
believe it's one and I hold one finger
up and say one and I look and it's
literally one,
you know, there's no confusion with
that. But you look in your fingers, you
say three. Is the oneness of my finger
the same as the oneness of Allah? Is the
oneness of your finger the same as the
oneness of Allah? Yes.
I have 10 fingers, my friend. No, no, I
have one finger that I'm putting up
right now. You know, when I put my one
finger up, is that oneness the same as
the oneness of Allah? If there's one
finger up and I say there's one Allah,
it should make sense to you. Is it the
same?
If there's Is there a
We got this. We're so close, Queen.
Look, is it is it the same? Is one. I'm
telling you, how do you know what the
oneness of Allah is like? But I cuz I
believe there's only one Allah. There's
only one God.
No, you believe that when you put your
finger up, the finger might be the same,
but how do you know that the oneness of
your finger is the same as the oneness
of Allah? What the hell are you even
talking about?
Listen, I'm not even trying to offend
you, right? I'm just trying to be as
honest as I can. No, I feel like you're
trying to use like semantics and like
trying to confuse me, but it's not going
to happen. I'm going to die on it.
He brought this example up. He's only
using your example. You said if I put If
I say Allah is one and I put one finger
up and show you one finger and I point
it up and say Allah is one, that would
make sense. So he's asking you. So is
Allah's oneness the same as the the one
finger that you're pointing up? Avery,
with all due respect, he's using
language that's like confusing. Not even
just for me, but for the masses. I have
the Arabic column Quran, the Warsh
Quran, and and the Hafs Quran. That's
three Qurans, right?
You would agree? That's three Qurans,
right? There's only one Quran. No, no,
no, no, I just my finger is like
if I Okay, you do the fingers thing with
me, right, Queen? So Yeah, how many
fingers are you holding up, say? So so
Qalun, right?
I I apologize. Mimi, I apologize. Look,
I'm look. So one finger up, right?
Qalun, right? That's one finger. Warsh
is another finger. These are two
different Arabics, by the way. Two
different Arabics.
And then Hafs, that's another Arabic
one. Okay.
How many fingers are you holding up?
Yeah, but you're talking about something
completely
like but like how many fingers though?
Okay, so tell me how many Bibles are
there? Please just answer. How many How
many fingers am I holding up? Mimi, did
you just say there's one Bible? Can you
Can you answer the question, be honest.
Avery, did you just say there's one
Bible?
I'm saying that there's three Qurans in
my hand right here. That's the problem.
My friend, like how many Bibles are
there? As many as there are Qurans. But
my problem is is this. When you say
Well, the problem is is this. You have
many Arabic Qurans, but yet you're still
able to say there's only one. What's
stopping a Christian from saying there's
only one God even though they can say
there's three persons? There's nothing
stopping them. You're just being
hypocritical, no offense, obviously.
What we're all saying
is that we both can recognize that God
can be one in one way
and then multiple in another way. You
have this You have this in your
religion. You have this in your
religion.
Uh
well, let me ask you this. Let me ask
you this, Mimi. How many attributes does
Allah have? How many names does Allah
have? Allah has 99 names, but it doesn't
mean he's 99 persons.
Exactly. So just because Allah can be 99
in his attributes, does not mean that
there are 99 Allahs
Yeah, I agree.
in the same way when we say that God is
multi multiple in his persons, No,
that's not the same thing. That's not
the same thing. That's not the same
thing. I'm trying
Oh my gosh. What we're trying What we're
trying What we're trying to get you to
is that God can be multiple in one way
and then one in another. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no. This point is clear. That point is
very clear. So you know, we're we're not
we're not going to keep going in circles
on this. I'm going to be honest, logic.
I think Muhammad was right about this
issue.
No, come on, bro. You come on, bro. You
guys are trying to get me You guys are
trying to get me to understand God one
way and look at him differently than how
I look at him. I believe there's Yeah,
but how do you know the way you're
looking at him is correct?
I believe that there's one God.
No sect has been given. How do you know
your way is straight?
And he has 99 names. You believe that
God is one, but he's three persons. This
is not the same thing.
We're just showing you, Mimi, that God
there's a there's categories. So when
we're saying that God is one in one way,
in one category, and he's multiple in
another category, that's the similarity
that Black Doctor was showing you. You
say that Allah is one in one way, yet
he's 99 in another way. Okay? Not So
it's just similar showing that there's
categories in that what we're talking
about. So when we say there's one God,
that's the way that he's one. There's
one divine essence. When we say there's
three persons, that's a different
category. We're not saying three gods.
Just like you're not saying 99 gods when
you say he has 99 names. Or 20 Qurans
when you say there's
What is What's your actual argument
about the deity of Christ?
Do you think Jesus is God or not? In the
Bible. I believe Jesus is a prophet and
we love him and we honor him, but I
don't believe he's God. Okay, why don't
you think he's God? Because God doesn't
have a picture. You can't encapsulate
vision.
I never had to encapsulate a divine
essence in my life.
Time's out. Time's out. You can't put a
picture to God. God doesn't Hold on. The
Hadith says that you can put a picture
to Allah. What are you talking about?
Who says that? The Hadith says that.
Mama says it. Where? That's all you had
to ask for. All you had to do was say
say where? Where is that Hadith? My
Muslim brothers and sisters, if I am not
doing it justice, you all got to come on
here and do it justice because I'm not a
scholar. I'm only going to say what I
believe and what I know. If
it's not good enough, then you got to
forgive me, make dua for me that I
increase my knowledge. That dua ain't
going to work. But please
Yeah, listen. We're going to get a lot
of this guy, you know.
Sahih Bukhari 4581.
Then Allah, the Lord of the worlds, will
come to them
in a shape nearest to the picture they
had in their minds about him. Okay. So
you can picture Allah and he's going to
show up in whatever you pictured him as.
Okay. Well, what have you to
It's in your mind, bro. And we'll only
see him on the day of judgment. Maybe
maybe we can build a picture for you,
right? You know when Allah says he has
right hands, right? When he has two
hands and both his hands are right. You
see the first image that was captured in
your mind, that's what's going to be
like. When he says he has a veil,
whatever you just thought of right now,
the first thought that came to your
mind,
that's what it is.
When it says that he has loins, whatever
you thought of right now, that's what it
is. That's that's what it is. Or like
the waistline, whatever that's called,
like that that's what it is. Um whatever
you just thought when he says that he
has a shin that he will show,
that's that's what it is.
Because the Lord of the worlds will come
to you in a shape closest to the picture
that you had in your mind. That one
right there.
Like the thing you just thought right
there. Right there. There it is. Right
there.
Yeah. Grip it with both hands as well.
With your left hand as well. And then
that's
right.
That's you. So Allah can be pictured. So
that's I mean Allah's not God now? No,
Allah has no pictures. I feel bad for
you all. For What do you mean you feel
bad for me? You should feel bad for
Allah. No, no, no. No,
no, no.
No, that's just crazy.
So is it Muhammad's fault that we have
this or did we just make it up? No, and
you guys claim to be philosophical
people and you're like, "Oh, no, look at
the text for what it is." But that's
what it says. What do you mean? Even
even Moses So me so me me me me.
Where did we read the text wrong?
Show us where we read the text wrong.
Yeah, but you're interpreting it the
wrong way. It's not like that. Maybe. So
how is it supposed to be interpreted,
ma'am? Why are you so condescending? I
I'm just trying to be respectful. Yeah,
see that's that's him trying to hit.
Maybe I should ask it. So how should we
understand this? Listen, God has no
picture. When you're saying his hands,
that's the only way we can understand
these things, right?
Yeah, but I what does hand mean? That's
why Allah gives us 99 of his 99
attributes so we can better understand
him. It doesn't necessarily point to a
picture of him. Like you guys, when you
think of God, you think of Jesus, long
hair, blue eyes, white guy, right?
my Jesus? No one No one thinks of blonde
hair, blue eyes, white guy. Well, what
do you think about when you think of
God? I don't think of the divine
essence. No one does. What do you think
about according to that Hadith? Why are
you trying to gaslight us like that's
not what it says, bro. So like why is it
the case? So so what So what So what
does So what does Muhammad mean when he
says that the law will appear to the
Ummah, to the believers, in a shape that
is closest to the image that they had in
their minds? What does that mean if it
doesn't mean exactly what we said
before? What does that mean, Mimi?
Why do you assume that it's just going
to be a human? We have like a Well, I'm
just asking you what it means. I didn't
assume anything. Yeah, what what does
Does it mean, Mimi, that he's going to
appear in a shape that's closest to the
picture that we have in our minds about
him? It's not going to be human form.
What What if I picture him What if I
picture him in human form?
Do you know that you're not always going
to be human, right? When you die, you
take a different form. You take a
different shape. What if I
No worries. What if I picture him in
human form? Will he show up in human
form? It's not going to be that way,
though.
It says that he will appear in a shape
closest to the image, the picture that I
have in my mind about him. So if I have
in my mind that he has a human shape,
then that's going to be the shape that
he shows up in according to the Hadith,
right? But
Sig, you just said that you don't
picture him as whatever you guys see him
as now. You just picture him as an
essence. We're talking about Allah. I
never said that. We're talking about
Allah.
So are you
Are you able to engage with what I'm
asking, Mimi, or No, because you guys
are saying two different things. Sig is
saying one thing, you're saying another
thing.
I didn't say anything. You asked two
different questions. You asked a
different question. We're now we're now
I'm getting you back focused on what the
Hadith says.
So I'll ask it again.
The Hadith says You're not going to make
me say You're not going to make me say
it. It's okay. I'm just I'm just reading
Hadith, Mimi.
Then Allah You can explain how he is in
a way that you understand.
The Lord of the worlds, Allah, will
come to them in a shape nearest
to the picture
that they had in their minds about him.
So whatever they pictured Allah,
whatever they imagined him to look like,
that's the shape that he's going to show
up in, correct?
Okay. So if
somebody pictures him in a human form,
then he will show up in a close that
closely in a shape that resembles human
form, right?
My belief is not this. I believe Jesus
is going to come down and tell you guys,
"Hey, look, you you
thinking the wrong one with God." You're
not answering the question. We're not
talking about Jesus. It's your mind.
That's the problem now. Because I don't
believe in
What does Muhammad What does Muhammad
say here in this Hadith? We didn't ask
you about what you believe. We asked
about what Muhammad said. I'm saying
you're interpreting it wrong. It's just
going to be explained to you in a way
that you can only understand. Okay. It's
right here.
She don't care, bro. She don't care no
more. I think we're I think we're done.
Yeah, that's crazy. Thanks for coming
up, Mimi. I appreciate it.
You know,
until next time, okay? I'mma let the
next guest up. Appreciate you, queen.
Yeah, yeah.